you brought back the blue so i have this
tweet here from brianna joy gray oh boy
she said marjorie taylor green is right
about the fbi bad faith or not
in today's radar i argue the left should
take advantage of the right's new
acknowledgement of systemic bias and
push to abolish the fbi
an institution that is always protected
has always protected elite power not the
people
my response to this was fire emojis i
know i completely agree i i i was
thinking i was like i'm actually a that
appeals to me um
but i mean i think that uh
sort of
i disagree a little bit about the fact
that both sides want stability i i don't
think that the other side wants
stability i think they want to remake
the world but this is not that this is
this is a
an appreciation and understanding that
the fbi at least
maybe maybe beyond enjoy gray in the
left perspective on this is we need to
tear down the system to rebuild a new
one don't no don't care if we have if we
if we look at the fbi and we're like hey
there's corruption going on there we
should defund that and and dismantle it
and they say yeah we also want to i'd
like well if we agree on that we're fine
moving forward we'll figure out
afterwards well then what here's the
problem
then what comes next yeah right like a
new organization that's even less
accountable yeah that we don't even know
i don't know and the tracks are you
cannot
you you can't say we should not do away
with corrupt institutions because of
fear of more corrupt institutions like
we're actually taking action to get rid
of but you can't like take a wheel off
the car mid mid drive yeah you have to
is that what the fbi is it's one of the
ones are they that important for the
united states have they been
investigating antifa have they been have
they been holding people accountable
have they been going after hunter biden
and i mean well we may see something
with hunter biden but it's been a really
long time and only because of public
scrutiny right so i'm not convinced
that first i'll say i don't think the
entirety of the fbi is corrupt i think
there's different people in different
field offices i've actually talked with
people who uh you know there's like
lower level people who there's fedex
they have similar politics to you the
culture war is in every facet of the
government as well
but
i just don't know if the fbi does
enough well no to warrant any of this i
mean it's a secret of operation that's
part of the problem it's not the
strength of it that's not what i'm
saying i'm not saying no one knows i'm
saying we have repeatedly asked
questions for years why have they not
done this that or otherwise yet they
have time to send a dozen agents to a
garage over a pole rope
that is shockingly
shockingly insane
you talking about the jesse smallett no
i'm talking about the
the watson was that his name i don't
know the nascar nascar driver said there
was a noose in his garage and so they
sent a dozen agents what did they find
it was a garage pole rope it was the
door pull rope
it's insane
and then they go and and merrick garland
signs off on rating the former
president's home and we're sitting here
being like let's contemplate whether
they're an organization worth funding no
no no no there's no question the left
has long talked about all of the
malfeasance they talk about martin
luther king and malcolm x's really big
examples and i'm like sure fine whatever
yeah
defund them dismantle them or maybe
maybe we can start by reducing through a
moderate defunding and reduction of the
fbi force yeah i mean i think the fbi
there's two problems one of them is
their it's the problem of every
government institution it's just
bureaucratic
bloat and
stupid people get
promoted and
your expertise and your it's not a
meritocracy is basically what i'm saying
i think that's a number one problem but
i think that in the last five years one
of the things that has become extremely
apparent is that the people who are in
charge like the grown-ups in charge i
always thought that there was grown-ups
in charge and then like
comey
he started talking and you're like oh my
god you had a lot of power and you are a
total nut job
but it's all of these people who were in
the top rungs of power who are not jobs
george conway is another one peter
fricken yeah
i was concerned with adam kinzinger i
don't know him personally but i've been
seeing his tweets and i think he's
isolated there seems to be like um a
bubble that some of these people are
existing in right now that they think
it's really what life is about is about
red and blue democrat republican thing
but that's like an infinitesimally small
part of reality yeah this human thing is
not that big a part of reality we need
to really kind of get outside of our own
butthole if you know what i'm talking
about and look out
look outside but that's what i said
bubble that's what i said butthole yeah
uh we need to we need to de-investigate
ourselves for a moment and look around
at the universe because things are
flying around at 100 million miles per
hour and can slam into earth at any
moment and we got to be prepared for
that kind of thing and and that
is an important mentality for people to
realize like you can find purpose
outside of all of this
most of these democrats this is their
life their religion their purpose they
have nothing else maybe if they
got interested in the stars they might
be like yo i don't care about this i
want to look in a telescope instead
their whole world i'll put it this way
politics has become pop culture yeah
that's that's the danger
and public health has become part of
their identity too i mean covet would
gave them a religion like most of them
i'm so happy that for you you finally
have found faith and it's you know in
the form of virus medication yep
although the cdc relax guidelines i
don't know if that's come up yet we
talked about before the show
officially uh i was according to npr
they reported on that today maybe going
into that later a little bit i i just
can't help thinking with the fbi there's
so much clear and evident mouse you can
look at peter strzok i just cherish the
way he smirked it was insane he looked
ideologically these people and blasey
ford did the same thing they do this
thing where they look in the camera and
they look down and go what the hell
what is that are you what are you are
you imagining you're the wicked witch of
the west or something
the problem is the camera's above like
what we got on the show so it's looking
down at them so you see like their eyes
looking up but
we we don't look to the camera turn our
heads down look up and then go
for yourself too creepy
we don't do that this episode
yeah well we're not hiding stuff i mean
why are they doing not more than a
normal person would hide some you know
menial personal or private things on tv
but like i think these people have to
have secret that's their job is like
secrecy half these people yeah in the
government the cia secrecy organization
oh it's all secrets yeah so that's the
remarkable thing is like anytime anyone
from the government comes out and says
words like why would you believe them
they have a whole system of keeping
information a secret from you they're
not going to tell you yeah i mean the
the the people who go to the white house
press conference
i'm just
do you really think
any white house press secretary at any
point ever is going to tell you the
truth i'm sorry if you believe that i
got a bridge to sell you you think the
first one did no first one no i mean the
thing is
the government trades in strategically
releasing information so why would that
be true in foreign policy and not true
in our
domestic media like why would we be like
oh yes american people i'm taking myself
i'm going to be on
national tv and i'm going to tell you
the truth but don't tell anyone else
because that'll reveal our big plan like
we
can't
reasonably expect our government to be
honest with us and also
be openly telling everyone all of our
adversaries like what's truly going on
with us like that seems like a terrible
plan yeah i mean i i i judge all of the
press secretaries by their ability to
lie yes and that's the job and suspect
and some of them are good and some of
them are not good and have you had a
favorite
oh gosh
so sarah huckabee sanders was fantastic
nothing
the key is and i think it's the bunch of
kids
nothing
nothing
yeah she's unflapping she's like come at
me and someone peed at me on my foot
today kaylee mcintyre was fantastic she
was so good being like here's the story
right here uh yes you're wrong yeah that
was fantastic
but uh jen sackey wasn't bad she was
like she wasn't yet yeah people you
might not like her but her ability to
spin and spin quickly and create sound
bites she know how to do it this this
current lady terrible oh man
she's terrible because they did a
checklist they were like well she checks
the lbgtq and she checks the woman and
she checks but they didn't actually like
have a check mark for charisma merit
for talent or anything yeah she's just
completely enacted i feel bad i know i
mean she's not over her head and she was
she was chosen because if she hit all
those little boxes and she has been from
what i know about her career i mean
she's been fairly insulated she's been
with the democratic movement for so long
i think people who are farther on the
outside of the the shell have to learn
how to spar a little bit more and i
think to her credit that's where jen
saki's background came from whereas with
uh christian pierre like no she has she
has been with the movement she knows the
sound bites and when challenged she
really struggles yeah no absolutely i
mean i think that was that's actually a
skill of like pete bootaj because he
like was in middle america and had to
actually talk to people with whom he
disagreed it makes me sharper i mean
that's how i felt
i went to rutgers university with like
every lib on on planet earth except
james o'keefe you know you know what
what really works though is believing
what you're saying yes that helps
because knowing what you're saying
because you don't need a book i mean
it's nice to have notes but you don't
need to look at them if you know if you
just glance down and then talk about
what you know you know i mean i'm here
with the formula stuff she genuinely had
no answer she didn't know that there was
a formula crisis she didn't know the
plan like she did not
there was no
there was nothing not to believe she
just didn't know it for the record
andrew johnson was the first president
to grant a formal interview to a
reporter wow that was 1869.
yeah so before that i guess they didn't
even they didn't even talk to the media
for the first 60 70 years it's kind of
crazy if you think about it i mean like
you have no idea what they're doing
i mean when was the last time biden
spoke to anyone he he rarely talks he
yells come on man quite a bit you know
with a helicopter
and i would argue to the first 50 60
years media was really different than
what it is yeah radio and tv have
changed a lot yeah i mean you have to
get a journalist to a president to then
put a paper out that would then like by
the time i reached anyone be like three
weeks old and i mean radio and tv is the
reason why hitler was able to mask the
population so fast and it's super
dangerous tech i understand why there's
censorship and why the the cia is
involved with you know the prism thing
and they want to oversee and make sure
but like
we should talk more about the power of
tv and video i think maybe not today but
i think in life tv was more powerful
than social media
with tv you had five channels starting
with three channels then five so all of
the messaging was distilled through the
trusted names and news or whatever then
the internet happened and you can reach
people faster but now you've got too
many channels yeah and they're all just
all these polls busted on the damn and
trying to plug them like oh we have
conventional fingers we don't know how
to plug all these at once i think make
an algorithm like the tick tock
algorithm people can get you know the
more they use it the more it knows them
and so it feeds them to like edgar allan
poe tick tock like that person is not
getting the same content that like you
would get or you would get it's true for
all the platforms true yeah but tick
tock is especially talented at it there
was the the wall street journal story
about
like young teenagers 13 14 years old and
they lingered on one pornographic video
and then they were just inundated with
more and more pornographic content yeah
that sounds like they're not better at
it no they're very good at it because
they got the kids hooked on the app
and it was because they just if you
lingered 0.3 seconds it's longer every
second on tick tock there is more
valuable to them partially because the
media is so short which keeps you
scrolling faster whereas like youtube
you may have to watch you know you watch
one video it might feed you another you
watch 10 videos it'll feed you right but
i mean our these videos are over an hour
like you really have to invest some time
but you can have like total add on
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you